[Musique]
il comparaît libre face au poids de
l'histoire jozsef chute est centenaire
son procès intervient 80 ans après les
faits qui lui sont reprochés
l'ancien caporal chef de la waffen ss
est poursuivi pour complicité dans le
meurtre de 3500 18 prisonniers dans un
camp de concentration nazi
l'accusé ne s'est pas exprimée pendant
le procès mais pour les avocats des
parties civiles l'essentiel n'est pas là
la particularité de ce procès c'est que
pendant des décennies la justice
allemande n'a plus mené de telles
procédures parce que ce n'est qu'en 2009
que la justice a repris son travail de
grenade
les victimes que nous représentons
partagent un objectif
qu'on parle encore aujourd'hui de ce
qu'il s'est passé dans les camps de
concentration
qu'on entretienne cette mémoire est qu'à
la fin on puisse prononcer une peine
juste
[Musique]
le procès se tient dans un gymnase
reconverti en tribunal non loin du
domicile de l'accusé afin de lui
épargner de longs déplacements
selon l'accusation le plus vieil accusés
de crimes nazis étaient entre 1942 et
1945 l'un des gardiens du camp de
sachsenhausen situé non loin de berlin
un épisode que l'accusé a tenu secret
toute sa vie jusqu'à ce que la justice
allemande ne rattrape
car pour le centre nationale d'enquêté
sur les crimes de guerre à ludwigsburg
dans le sud du pays la chasse aux nazis
n'est pas fini
voici notre fichier central il contient
en tout presque 1,8 millions de fiches
c'est ici que commence chaque enquête
menée par le centre national de
ludwigsburg on trouve ici tous les
accusés tous les témoins de toutes les
enquêtes menées ici depuis la fin des
années 50
depuis sa création en 1958 les
procureurs du centre comme michel autès
sont chargés de poursuivre les criminels
de guerre nazis
130000 procédure et plus de 7000 enquête
préliminaire qui ont conduit notamment
au célèbre procès d'auschwitz dans les
années 1960
mais ces derniers avaient marqué la fin
des grands procès de criminels de guerre
nazis ce n'est qu'en 2011 avec la sphère
john demir new qu'un ancien garde du
camp d'extermination de sobibor que la
justice a repris ses droits depuis ce
procès une activité avérée dans un camp
de la mort sufit a condamné des
criminels de guerre alors les chasseurs
de nazis se livrent à une course contre
la montre
le procès de d'aignan nuke nous a
conduits à enquêter à nouveau dans le
détail sur tous les camps de
concentration dans lesquelles des crimes
systématiques ont eu lieu nous avons
minutieusement analysés tous les
documents relatifs au personnel qui
travaillait dans ces camps bientôt il ne
restera plus de criminels en vie et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
travaillons avec une attention toute
particulière sur ces dossiers
une justice tardive qui a toutefois
permis de condamner quatre anciens ss
pour complicité de meurtres à des peines
souvent symbolique en raison de leur
grand âge
jozsef chute est lui aussi accusé
d'avoir contribué à la machinerie nazis
par son travail de gardien de caen à
sachsenhausen sur les deux cent mille
détenus des opposants politiques des
juifs des homosexuels mais aussi des
prisonniers de guerre soviétiques plus
d'un car ils y ont trouvé la mort alors
pour l'une des historiennes en charge du
mémorial de sachsenhausen cette justice
n'est pas que mémorielle
c'est un signal important dans le
contexte politique actuel en ukraine
avec des crimes de guerre qui sont à
nouveau commis en europe
cela montre que dans un état
démocratique
la poursuite de ce genre de crime peut
intervenir très longtemps après les
faits
cela est dû à l'histoire de
l'après-guerre à l'histoire de la
justice
mais cela arrive un jour où l'autre
en tant que victime aux descendants de
victimes on peut donc compter dessus et
en tant que criminel il faut s'y
préparer
le parquet allemand a requis cinq ans de
prison contre yosef chute une dizaine de
criminels de guerre présumés font encore
l'objet d' enquête préliminaire en
allemagne tous sont désormais plus de 90
ans